bienvenidos a él a sandino desde caracas
venezuela el tema principal de hoy será
la reconversión monetaria que entró en
vigencia el 1º de octubre y con la que
se suprimieron 6 0 al bolívar a la
moneda local con esta medida el gobierno
de nicolás maduro espera mejorar las
transacciones de pago también hablaremos
de como los productos importados
aliviaron la fuerte escasez de alimentos
que vivió este país durante tres años y
sobre la competencia desleal que han
iniciado los productores nacionales
esta es la tercera reconversión
monetaria en venezuela bajo la
denominada revolución chavista en 13
años a la moneda se le han eliminado 14
ceros en total 3 en el año 2008 con el
gobierno del fallecido hugo chávez y el
resto bajo la administración del
presidente nicolás maduro con esta
última reconversión denominada bolívar
digital se busca agilizar trámites
financieros debido a las graves
consecuencias que ha generado el
desbordamiento de dígitos por la
inflación que cerrará este 2021 dos mil
seiscientos sesenta y siete por ciento
según estimaciones independientes en los
últimos dos años bolívar ha perdido 98
85 por ciento de su valor si se toma
como referencia el curso del dólar para
tamara herrera economista y directora de
la firma síntesis financiera esta
reconversión monetaria no es una
solución al problema de fondo pero sí
traerá un alivio para los pagos el
crecimiento de la inflación lleva a que
el valor de las cosas tenga tantos
dígitos cuando los expresas que los
sistemas empiezan a congestionarse y
empieza a ocurrir ese desbordamiento de
los vistos entonces el desbordamiento de
los dígitos es de una cosa que tenía a
las empresas fraccionando operaciones
facturas y estaba generando aumentos de
costos e inoperancia gigantescas para
sacar un camión cualquiera de cualquier
producto con una hiperinflación presente
en venezuela desde finales del año 2017
cuando alcanzó los seis dígitos la
moneda perdió valor los billetes
comenzaron a escasear y se generó un
colapso en los sistemas de pago que se
mantiene hasta ahora y desde 2019 el
dólar se impuso como moneda de facto en
venezuela sin que el gobierno opusiera
resistencia tras años de satanizar su
uso en un país donde no todos ganan en
divisas desde la gasolina hasta un perro
caliente en la calle se paga en dólares
a precios internacionales los salarios
de los venezolanos equivalen entre 4
dólares en el sector público y 90 en el
mejor de los casos y esto ha generado
mayores brechas de desigualdad y pobreza
aunque la dolarización la presentan como
una válvula de escape a la crisis
también causa problemas cotidianos como
la dificultad de dar vueltos en dólares
de baja denominación porque el país no
genera divisas
para dar guardo por lo que es la divisa
es complicado porque la mayoría de la
gente viene con 5 con 10 y los de 1 es
muy difícil bueno ya hasta los de 5 es
difícil tener entonces imagínate si
vendes un cuarto aunque sean 4 dólares
te pagan con un billete de 10 minutos el
cambio pierdes la venta en casi todos
los establecimientos comerciales del
país los carteles con la lista de
precios están marcados en dólares muchos
comerciantes tienen que usar el ingenio
para no perder ventas ante la dificultad
para dar vuelta algunos clientes reciben
su cambio mediante una especie de vale
como sully santiago que los recibió con
queja me dan un vale yo voy a el día
siguiente a buscar lo que me quedaron
sean 10 sean 5 sean 20 no hay entonces
tengo que con lo que tengo ahí tengo que
volver a comprar
porque nunca he vuelto según los
expertos de no atacar el problema de
fondo la inflación se estima que en 4 ó
5 años se esté dando otra reconversión
monetaria
entretanto con la dolarización
transaccional en venezuela comenzó la
proliferación de bodegones o negocios
llenos de productos del extranjero que
dejaron atrás periodos de profunda
escasez de alimentos y largas filas para
adquirir productos básicos
el boom de los bodegones coincidió con
la exoneración de aranceles que el
gobierno de maduro hizo hace tres años a
las importaciones de 3000 artículos para
paliar la falta de alimentos que vivió
venezuela entre 2015 y 2017
desde leche de almendras de estados
unidos hasta falafel del líbano o
cervezas importadas hoy todo se consigue
en estos establecimientos los
productores locales han sido los más
afectados con esta medida mientras los
importadores pueden traer productos
terminados sin pagar impuestos ellos se
enfrentan a altos aranceles al comprar
materia prima para producir para el
momento el sector agrícola solo produce
entre 20 y 25 por ciento de la demanda
nacional una caída sustancial con
respecto al 70 por ciento que se
producía en 2009
los anaqueles por ahora están
abastecidos pero la mayoría de los
ciudadanos no tienen poder de comprar
según estudios de la universidad
católica andrés bello la pobreza extrema
en venezuela se ubica en 70 y 9.3 por
ciento hasta aquí éste enlazan vino
desde la ciudad de caracas pueden
sintonizar nuestros programas a través
de france 24 y france 24 puntocom